So Leute da bin ich, ist noch früh aber ich bin schon ungefähr 1 Stunde auf aber ich
bin nicht wach. Oder sag mal wach ist was anderes. Sagt mal hat irgendjemand diesen
Overwatch 2 Reveal Stream gesehen der vor ein paar Tagen war? Das war aber nicht Stream,
jedoch ja war mal ein Stream ich hab das als Wort geguckt. Das war wieder sehr viel gequatsche um
nichts. Wirkte fast so als kämpft die Marketing Abteilung mit dem Entwicklungsteam was denn
jetzt eigentlich da gemacht werden soll. Wann ist eigentlich Release Date? Also aktuell schockt es
mich ok Oktober. Aktuell schockt es mich so überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß nicht es ist ja auch
das hat sich auch nichts von dem verändert was mich genervt hat und ich glaube nicht dass Blizzard
an den eigentlichen Problem die das Game hat. Vor allem der Support wie es jahrelang jetzt
gelaufen ist dass sich da großartig was dran ändert nicht so viele Hoffnungen drin. Moin Leute
also ich weiß nicht wie lange ich jetzt on bin ich bin übelst im Arsch noch kann euch gar nicht
so genau sagen warum. Aber irgendwie bin ich im Arsch. Ich muss ich muss am Dienstag wisst ihr was
ich was ich da tolles machen muss auf der Arbeit. Real Razor Chief danke für den Sub. Wisst ihr was
ich da tolles machen muss ich muss mit einem Techniker aus den USA auf irgendeiner Cloud
Linux VM mit dem zusammen was installieren. Bin ich mal gespannt was da rauskommt. Irgendwas was
ich noch nie im Leben installiert habe der soll mir irgendwie sagen was ich machen muss.
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht ich habe mir auch schon gedacht warum geben wir dem nicht
einfach remote Zugkräfte kann er selbst machen. Aber man weiß ja nie. Tja gab es sonst was
spannend das die letzten Tage über. Ich habe eine ich habe eine China-Chinesen Sponsoring Anfrage
bekommen. Muss ich euch mal vorlesen. Da keckt ihr euch weg. Die fängt schon an mit die fängt
schon an mit irgendeiner. Keine Ahnung. China-Chinesen Zeichen E-Mail und es fängt an. Hello my old friend.
Hello my old friend. My dear. Das ist China-Chinesen Text übersetzt ins Englische. So fangen
natürlich alle Sponsoring Anfragen immer an. Die Chinesen. Und was wollen sie mir. Was wollen
sie mir aufschwätzen. Sie wollen mir ein ultra holdable und comfortable 48 Megapixel
Main Kamera. Was wollen die mir überhaupt aufschwätzen. Ein Smartphone. Ob die wollen
wir ein Smartphone aufschwätzen. Keine Ahnung. Ja oh man. Free Crap braucht auch keiner.
Möll kriegt man eben auch sonst. Aber was gescheites. Die wollen dann ja auch was dafür
haben und das sehe ich nicht ein. Ich bewerbe so ein Crap nicht. Ich mache eh relativ wenig
Sellouts. Ich mache eigentlich nie großartig Sellouts. Ich habe die letzten Jahre über
was habe ich gemacht. Hetzner habe ich gemacht. Das würde ich auch weiter machen. Weil ich
den Crap eben benutze. Und das auch ohne Sponsoring teilweise schon hier im Stream gezeigt
habe. Ja dann habe ich dieses Battlefield Sponsoring gemacht. Wo man gemerkt hat dass
ich keinen Bock mehr auf die Sponsorings hatte nach zwei Videos. Aber ich habe mir den halt
drei Videos ausgemacht. Ja gut was willst du machen. Ansonsten. Ich habe irgendeinen
Sniper Elite Sponsoring habe ich mal gemacht die letzten Jahre über. Die sind bei mir
auch laufend am Start. Und VPN Anbieter sind auch laufend am Start. Und wisst ihr was lustig
ist. Ich habe das ja schon erzählt. Die waren doch neulich sogar im Chat. Echt jetzt. Im
Stream. Wirklich habe ich keine mitbekommen. Oder vor oder nach dem Stream. Naja. Was gibt
es eigentlich einen einfachen Weg. Wo ist die Frage. Gibt es eigentlich auch einen einfachen
Weg. Ein C++. Ja klar. Es ist jetzt egal ob es GCC ist oder LLVM Clang. Wie auch immer
man das ausspricht. Genau. Ja. Kannst du alles installieren. Aber was ich gerne mache ist
ich verwende für diesen Krempel ein Pack. Ja super. Massive. Massive Größe. Ich verwende
ein Package Manager für Windows. Ja da ist alles mögliche drinne. Search. GCC. Ich muss
mal updaten wieder. Ich meine es ist Windows deswegen ist es nicht schnell. Aber ansonsten
gibt es bestimmt komplett fertige C++ Entwicklungs Bundles für Windows. Achso. Wenn du den Microsoft
Krempel verwenden willst dann kannst du auch einfach. Das stimmt da habe ich gar nicht
dran gedacht. Ja klar. Du kannst doch den Visual Studio Kram installieren mit dem ganzen
Microsoft Krempel. Das geht auch. Wahrscheinlich unter Windows sogar die beste Variante.
RealRenax. Doch hatte ich. Aber das ist nichts geworden. Die haben sich das anders überlegt.
Also ne. Die haben sich nicht anders überlegt. Die haben gesagt der Termin ändert sich.
Und dann habe ich gesagt ne zu dem neuen Termin passt das bei mir nicht. Und seitdem habe
ich nie wieder was gehört. Ne ne ne. Also Visual Studio ist die Community Community Edition
ist free. Welchen Package Manager ich verwende. Scoop. Den da. Es gibt dann auch noch. Es
gibt dann auch noch den da. Weiß gar nicht ob ich das installiert habe. Ne. Also der
Scoop installiert rein lokal ins Heimatverzeichnis. Der andere System weit. Ich finde das ist mit
den Heimat ins Heimatverzeichnis besser. Ja du kannst ohne. Absoluter Crap. Also ich
meine mittlerweile mittlerweile ist es benutzbar. Mittlerweile ist es benutzbar. Weil mal gucken
was auf GitHub da abgeht. Mittlerweile ist es benutzbar weil sie den Kram wenigstens
so eingerichtet haben dass du mittlerweile Software deinstallieren kannst. Aber ganz
ehrlich das. Also ich bin nicht sonderlich begeistert von von WinGit. Ich müsste mir
es aber mal wieder angucken. Ich muss also das letzte Mal wo ich es mir angeguckt habe
ging das deinstallieren von Software noch nicht mal. Mittlerweile geht das aber. Was
ich ganz gut mag ist dass es ähnlich ist zu Pacman oder UpGit oder sonst was. Ich müsste
ich müsste mir den Kram mal wieder angucken ob das mittlerweile taugt. Ich bin mir halt
nicht sicher ob es dort überhaupt genug Packages gibt also sprich welche Sources verwendet
das Ding. Müsste man mal ausprobieren. Ah ok. Als letztes Mal hat mich WinGit komplett
kalt gelassen. Du könnt mal vielleicht jetzt mal im Stream angucken aber dafür ein extra
Stream machen ist glaube ich unsinnig. Das dauert eine halbe Stunde sich das anzugucken
mit allem drum und dran und dann ist gut. War gerade eine Chat guckt ihr mal zufällig
die Orville Season 3. Ich fand ja Season 1 wirklich richtig gut also Massive Pork. Season
2 fand ich zum größten Teil auch ziemlich gut aber die ersten drei Folgen von Season
3 finde ich auch wieder richtig gut. Also besseres Star Trek als Star Trek. Also gefällt
mir echt gut. Und ich feier wenige Serien so richtig. Ja gibt es aktuell nur auf Englisch
kann man aber schon beispielsweise über Amazon oder irgendwelche anderen Stream. Mein Original
sind die jetzt irgendwie auf Disney plus oder auf Hulu oder was auch immer. WTF. Wusste
ich bis dann nicht mal dass es das überhaupt gibt. Aber man kann sich das auf Amazon angucken.
Bezahle ich halt zwei Euro pro Folge oder so. Was mir ein bisschen auf den Keks geht ist
dass die Folgen halt wieder einmal also jeden Freitag die Woche rauskommen und nicht einfach
am Stück aber ja so ist das halt. Manche stehen also auf das Serien Feeling. The Boys habe
ich aufgehört zu gucken nach Anfang Staffel 2. Also Staffel 1 fand ich zum größten Teil
ziemlich nice. Vom Ende hinher war es ein bisschen langweilig aber der Rest also Staffel
2 hat mir dann schon gar nicht mehr großartig gefallen. Aber wie gesagt ich bin da eh. Also
es gibt viele Serien die ich gut fand. Eins zwei Staffeln. Und dann kam irgendwas was
mir nicht mehr gefallen hatte. Dann hör ich auf zu gucken. Also ich glaube ich hab ganz
ganz wenige Sachen wirklich komplett geguckt. Achja. So. Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Das können wir uns dann angucken. Was gibt's dann? Was haben wir denn? Was haben wir denn
noch als Spannendes? Hat sich ein Jahr warten auf das Steam Deck gelohnt? Eher nicht. Which
Battlefield Games are dead? Also wirklich dead? Komplett ohne Spieler? Dürfte wahrscheinlich
nur die ganz alten sein. So Vietnam und sonst was. Selbst BC2 und so kannst du ab und zu
noch ein bisschen spielen. Aber wenn man dead sagt weniger als fünf aktive Server oder
so dann sind das ganz schön viele. Expans hab ich auch geguckt Staffel 1 bis eineinhalb.
Wo sind die Entwickler hin? Ich bin immer noch da.
Battlefield 2042 Geheimnis aufgeklärt.
Was war das gerade? Leute ich hab da beim Refresh und habt ihr es auch gesehen? Ah da
ist es. Wollte ich gerade sagen ich hab doch irgendwelchen Weep Kram gerade beim Screen
Refresh gesehen. Die meinen unbedingt dass wir das gucken sollen. Aber ich will jetzt
nicht den Ventilator Teaser gucken. Das hört sich schon länger ein bisschen geltzwertig
an. Naja. So. Das schauen wir uns an. Es gibt nicht viel Gescheites. Ne. Und was? Was
ich diese Woche gesehen hab? Die Doku über die Cyber Polizistin wurde die Woche über
10 Parts gesplitzt. Ja du meinst über die Cyber Polizistin wo es in dem ganzen Beitrag
vielleicht eine Minute um Cyber ging? Ne. Neues Video zur E3. Juckt mich so gar nicht
was auf der E3 passiert ist. War die überhaupt schon? Achja das war das wo sie dieses klar
das war doch wo sie dieses Open World Sonic gezeigt haben. Wo sich alle weggekackt haben.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Das sah richtig fail aus. Ach das war Summerfest. Ach keine Ahnung.
Juckt mich nicht. Man hat seit Corona gesehen dass Messen eigentlich total overrated outdated
she baited sind. Die Gamescom war noch nie sinnvoll. Nicht für Spiele. Die Gamescom
ist vielleicht ein Event für viele wo man vor Ort sich mit Leuten trifft die man lange
nicht gesehen hat. Also die Gamescom ist für viele eher so ein Real Life Event weniger
Gaming Messe. Weil Spielen kannst du auf der Gamescom eh vergessen. Das heißt du willst
3 Stunden anstehen für irgendwas. Und selbst wenn man da im Vorfeld Termine macht. Und
dass man dann auch Sachen gezeigt bekommt. Selbst dann ist es nicht sonderlich spannend
oder sinnvoll. Also die Gamescom ist komplett umsonst gewesen. Also nicht preislich. Komplett
unsinnig gewesen. Deswegen gehe ich da auch schon seit Jahren nicht mehr hin und ob die
jemals wieder in der alten Form stattfinden wird keine Ahnung. Mal gucken wie es dieses
Jahr wird. Es soll ja dieses Jahr genau das habe ich auch. Also es soll ja dieses Jahr
ganz normal stattfinden. Ich bin mal gespannt in welchem Umfang und wie das ist. Ob das
dann wieder wie vor Corona ist oder nicht. Da sind sie aber selbst dran schuld wenn sie
so einen Müll vorstellen oder? Ich mein dann muss man sich ja nicht den Leuten überlassen
sich das zusammen zu reimen. Sondern könnte einfach was ordentliches zeigen. Oder man
lässt es halt bleiben und zeigt was ordentliches wenn man was ordentliches zeigen kann. Ich
muss sagen es waren die letzten Jahre so wenige AAA Spiele dabei auf die ich mich A gefreut
habe und B als sie dann rausgekommen sind auch wirklich was getaugt haben. Also das
letzte negativ Beispiel was mir dazu einfällt ist einfach Battlefield 2042. Da habe ich
mich nachdem nachdem es so die ersten Sachen gab habe ich mich mega drauf gefreut und
habe gesagt endlich mal wieder was modernes Battlefield Technik. Ich habe ja auch Videos
zugemacht. Das sieht auch gut aus was man gesehen hat. Aber es wurde halt komplett verschissen.
Ich habe ja damals als sie den Trailer hatten hatte ich ja mit dem Lost. Da haben wir zwei
drei Stunden uns darüber ausgelassen und haben das besprochen wie man beide übelst
gehyped hat drauf. Und man muss sagen die einzige Abteilung die wirklich einen richtig
guten Job gemacht hat bei Battlefield 2042 ist die Marketing Abteilung. Die haben es
drauf gehabt. Also zumindest am Anfang. Mittlerweile ja auch nicht mehr. Was gibt es da gibt es
ja auch ein wenig noch schön zu reden. Aber alles was dann aber was ich witzig fand.
Wir haben es lustigerweise in dem Stream damals sogar schon damals sogar schon gesagt. So
nach dem Motto Alter alles mega geil. Sonst wie kann sich am Ende trotzdem wie kurze spielen
und wir hatten recht. Es spielt sich am Ende wie kurze. Es geht wahrscheinlich Waffen sind
nicht mehr in mein Amis. Die stehen da immer noch drauf Waffen daheim zu haben. Aber in
den letzten Jahren hat man gesehen dass viel mehr Games weggehen davon realistische Waffen
im Spiel darzustellen. Also ich rede jetzt nicht von Schwertern und Äxten und sowas.
Das letzte hast du auch gesehen. Das wieder dass sie dann angefangen haben jetzt in Battlefield
2042 die Waffen nachzubauen aber den anderen Namen zu geben und sowas. Okay wahrscheinlich
ist es viel schneller. Eisfliegt. Danke. Danke für den Zap. Ich brauche übrigens unbedingt
mal neue. Echt tatsächlich. Ich hätte gedacht das ist deutlich weniger. Ich brauche unbedingt
wieder neue Subscriber Dinger. Ich meine du bekommst glaube ich den nach einem Jahr bekommst
du den goldenen Keks mit mit Halskette. Habt ihr eine gute Idee was man noch machen kann.
Ansonsten muss ich mal in mich gehen. Man könnte man könnte den sicherlich noch noch
ausbauen. Den Gold Keks. Eine Knarre. Ein Hut in Hut. Das das Problem ist Hut kann man
nicht machen. Also wisst ihr dass das tatsächlich ziemlich fai fertig ist solche Dinger zu
designen. Weil dem kannst du beispielsweise kein Hut aufsetzen dem Keks warum. Weil wenn
man einen Hut nimmt. Wenn man einen Hut nimmt. Dieses Bild ist immer das gleiche Seitenverhältnis
wenn man einen Hut nimmt dann nimmt das hier oben die Ecke weg und der ganze Keks wird
kleiner weil das Seitenverhältnis von dem Bild gleich bleibt und du erkennst den Keks
nicht mehr. Also du kannst eigentlich nur was machen was du an diesem Keks selbst machst
du kannst nichts um diesen Keks machen. Deswegen gibt es hier auch keinen mit Headset weil
das weil das kacke aussieht in klein. Ja genau also es ist gar nicht so gar nicht so einfach
sowas zu designen. Die Augenfarbe kann man zum Beispiel machen oder Keksfarbe oder was
der um den Hals hat oder vielleicht was er was in der Hand hat oder vielleicht hier oben
so ein Stirnband keine Ahnung irgendwie so aber du kannst ansonsten kannst du nichts
machen das muss. Ghostface. Ja das könnte sowas so Dinger Sonnenbrille ja tatsächlich
ja ja genau genau das das geht natürlich auch sowas es ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Klar am Mittag war es hoch. Ich habe jetzt jemand der mir Stream Highlights zusammenschneidet
richtig gut finde ich. Es haben ja schon ein paar Leute Probe geguckt manche haben gesagt
Cringe Humor wobei ich es gar nicht so schlimm finde ich finde es passt eigentlich ziemlich
gut aber die meisten fanden es gut. Ich bin mal gespannt das ist nämlich eine super Alternative
dass ich weil ich bin jetzt ja nicht gerade die krasse Contentmaschine was YouTube Videos
angeht ich mache alle keine Ahnung 14 Tage in einem Video oder so aktuell oder wenn was
ist und es gibt doch im Stream ab und an die ein oder anderen interessanten Dinger was
wir uns mal angucken wo wir uns mal darüber auslassen und wenn das jemand zusammenschneidet
von meinem 45 Minuten Stunden Gelaber zu unter 10 Minuten ist das finde ich recht unterhaltsam
das können wir uns ja am Mittag angucken also was heißt wir wir nicht also ihr könnt euch
das angucken wenn ich hochgeladen habe. Die meisten Leute die öfters im Stream dabei
sind vielleicht sogar dabei wo ich es erzählt habe aber wir mal gucken. Das ist ja kein
Ersatz für irgendwie Content ansonsten gäbe es einfach kein Content bis man wieder danach
ist alle zwei bis drei Wochen ein Video aufzunehmen so gibt es vielleicht öfters mal was und
ich finde das richtig gut geschnitten. So YouTube letzte Chance. Letzte Chance empfehlt mir
was gescheites. Wo wollte es das so. Das schrecklichste Release der Playstation 3. Ach so die ja gut
also eines der schlimmsten Sachen was Konsolen Ankündigungen angeht fand ich immer noch
die Xbox One. Also die Xbox One das war so how to verkacken any percent also das war
kompletter Schwachsinn. Erinnert ihr euch noch. Erinnert ihr euch noch dran als die war
der Xbox One Präsentation ernsthaft irgendwelche Football Games oder Basketball ich glaube
Football war es irgendwelche Football Games gezeigt haben und dann erzählt haben wie geil
das ist dass man sich im Auferlei einblenden kann auf der Xbox One für die Football Games
und da haben halt alle sich gedacht. Ja ok. Kikona Staff. TV TV. Ja genau. Wo ich immer
noch nicht gecheckt habe was zum Teufel haben die da getrieben und sich gedacht was geht
da. Wie schnell das Geld mit Fishing weg ist. Ok der NDR Ratgeber erklärt uns das. Aber
17 Minuten. Irgendwann. So da hinten so. Ich mein für irgendwas muss ich ja meine Gebühren
bezahlen. So viel kriegen YouTuber. Ach gibt's mal wieder hier. Ich habe alle Placements
angenommen. Das war gar nicht schlecht das Video. Das letzte fand ich eigentlich ganz
gut. Cave Exploring Gone Wrong. Alles klar. Der Kerle ist immer noch am Tunnelgraben.
Das haben wir doch vor einem Jahr zuletzt geguckt. Wir haben doch vor einem Jahr oder
so mal ein Video von ihm geguckt. Wo er angefangen hat den Tunnel zu buddeln. Ok so ein Tunnel
buddelt sich wahrscheinlich nicht so easy einfach mal so. Dauert wohl eine Weile. Na gut.
Kauf zwei dann hast du eine. Wie man muss zwei Packages kaufen dass man eine Pyramide
bekommt. Wirklich. Das ist ja Massive 5 Fett Geld machen. 5 Fett Money Makin. Windows Defender
now available for all platforms. Das ist doch jetzt schon. Ok auf iOS. Also wir haben auf
unsere Linux Server schon lange. Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection. Ich finde es mega
beschissen und ich habe das an einigen Stellen auch schon gesagt. Aber alle sagen sich ja
aber Security das muss sein. Wir brauchen Advanced Threat Protection auf allen Linux
Systemen. Das Ding also wir hatten dadurch noch keinen Vorteil wir hatten bisher nur Nachteile.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich das Microsoft die Advanced Threat Protection live patchen kann. Also
damit hat quasi Microsoft ein Backdoor auf jedem deiner Server. Also der Windows Defender
patcht sich live angeblich irgendwelche Updates allerdings können die nicht nur Updates patchen
sondern auch wirklich Funktionen am Defender. Das heißt sobald du Windows Advanced Threat
Protection auf deinem Linux Server drauf hast hast du effektiv ein Microsoft Backdoor auf
deiner Kiste. Also was auch wer diesen Scheiß ernsthaft installiert und wer im Management
diesen Schwachsinn entscheidet das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Passwörter mittlich
zu dem Klartext speichern. Ja das hatten wir auch schon. Wie gesagt ich habe schon Passwörter
im Klartext in irgendwelchen Defender Logs gefunden. Ok komm gucken wir gleich erstmal
erstmal den Level Cap Gbait. Leute der tägliche, jährliche, monatliche, wöchentliche Level
Cap Gbait. Das muss sein. Lass uns mal Level Cap Gbaiten. Hast du das Drama um Googles
AI mitbekommen? Ne was war? Was war das Drama? Was war das Drama um Googles AI? Hab ich
nicht mitbekommen. Ich kann mich noch an das Drama über Microsofts Nazi AI erinnern.
Weiß das noch jemand? Microsoft hat mal ein Twitter Bot gemacht. Was ist das denn hier?
Microsoft hat mal ein Twitter Bot rausgebracht der lernen sollte wie man auf Twitter eben
mit Leuten kommuniziert. Genau genau dieses Ding meine ich. Also Microsoft hat mal einen
Bot auf Twitter rausgebracht der aus Twitter lernen soll wie man auf Twitter kommuniziert.
Das Problem war dass der nach ein paar Tagen nur noch Nazi Kommentare und rechtsextreme
Sachen gepaustet hat. Also da denkt man sich auch Alter. Das hätten die sich auch denken
können. Weil ganz im Ernst, dass die Leute wenn die das mitbekommen nicht normal diesen
Bot antworten. Mich würd's nicht wundern wenn da 4chan wieder dran beteiligt war im Zweifelsfall.
Hat Chatbot Lambda ein Bewusstsein entwickelt? Okay lass mal abkürzen. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Google Burlaub Angestellten. Aha. Weil bei Google niemand diese Überzeugung geteilt
hat. Alter die haben alle Dachschaden man. Was zum Teufel hat es denn jetzt mit religiösen
Überzeugungen zu tun? Also sprich er behauptet, nur dass ich das mal richtig verstehe. Er
behauptet sein Chatbot hätte Self-Awareness entwickelt und bei Google sagen alle andere
die das sehen, nee kann nicht sein du hast doch nicht mehr alle. Und dann sagt er ja
das macht nix ich muss einfach nur dran glauben und hat sich jetzt darüber beschwert dass
man ihn diskriminieren würde weil. Hä? Das ist auch wieder was was nur im Jahr 2022 passieren
kann. Wahrscheinlich. Der Alkohol muss wohl mit aber.
Okay. Stattdessen hätten sie wiederholen seine Gesundheit in Frage gestellt. Ja kann
ich mir schon vorstellen dass da einige Dachschaden haben. Also ich tendiere ich tendiere in dem
Fall auch ob ohne ohne diesen Chatbot zu kennen. Ich tendiere auch eher zu dass der Kerl im
Dachschaden hat. Da bin ich mal gespannt was da noch raus kommt. Mittlerweile sind Bots
eh schon an der an der Grenze das wo man sich fragt. Hat das nicht vielleicht doch
irgendein Mensch gemacht? Also auch die wie heißt diese Übersetze wie heißt diese Übersetzungsseite?
War das Dieb L? Ich weiß nicht. Das ist auch ziemlich gut mittlerweile. Ja das ist das ist
auch das ist auch ziemlich gut mittlerweile und ich gehe auch davon aus dass man das
in ein paar Jahren nur noch äußerst schwer auseinanderhalten kann. Aber gerade was Übersetzung
angeht fände ich das POG. Wisst ihr was was ich finde man ist in manchen Bereichen sind
wir deutlich besser in dem was man sich also zu dem was man sich in irgendwelchen Science
Fiction Filmen vorgestellt hat für in 300 Jahren sind wir jetzt schon besser und in
manchen Bereichen haben wir noch gar nichts auf die Reihe gekriegt. Ja zum Beispiel wenn
man sich mal ältere Science Fiction Filme anguckt da hatten die ja auch immer irgendwelche
Kommunikator Devices wo sie dann halt ich sage mal gefunkt haben und oder kommuniziert
haben und diese Dinger sind alle um ein Vielfaches schlechter und und klobischer und größer
und und ja in allen belangen schlechter als irgendwo modernes Smartphone. Also da sind
wir deutlich besser als ich das noch Science Fiction Sendungen von vor 30 Jahren vorstellen
konnten aber in anderen Bereichen gar nicht. Ja das wundert mich nicht. Bei uns ist es
so wir haben eine Zeiterfassungs Software die hatte bis vor ein paar Versionen stand da
immer noch drinnen wenn du die gestartet hast optimiert für Microsoft Internet Explorer.
Wisst ihr was ich bei manchen Moment das muss ich euch mal zeigen Internet off shit. Internet
off shit. Da gibt es teilweise Bilder von hier guckt mal Elektro. Manche modernen Autos
musst du jetzt Updates machen also du kannst nicht einfach mit deinem Auto fahren du musst
jetzt einfach 15 Minuten neben stehen bleiben und warten bis das Software Update durch ist.
Also das ist was was mir persönlich ja irgendwie wieder strebt. Also wenn ich schon ein Auto
habe dann möchte ich das mit dem Auto auch exakt dann benutzen können wann ich will und
der das man Software Updates machen kann und sollte ist ja alles in Ordnung. Aber wenn
schon wenn ich wenn schon wenn ich nicht drinnen bin oder aber dass ich sagen kann nein ich
fahre jetzt erstmal. Das ist halt echt schon heftig wenn du dir überlegst so nach dem
Motto ich will jetzt mit dem Auto losfahren und dann nein du fährst nicht los du machst
jetzt erstmal ein Update. Ja sollte auch so sein das kann nicht sein dass du da warten
musst aber trotzdem also was ist wirklich richtig hier hingeblieben. Toaster mit Homescreen
ja warum nicht. Nicht jedes Gerät was man smart machen kann macht man smart damit indem
man ein Display dran pappt das ist auch so ein Ding guck mal. Ich vermute mal dass es
äußerst sinnlos ist dass dieser Toaster quasi ein Homescreen hat. Man könnte guckt euch
ok bestes Beispiel Kühlschränke. Es gäbe so viele coole Möglichkeiten Kühlschränke
smart zu machen. Die könnten verschiedene Fächer haben man könnte das automatisch wiegen
dass du den Stand weißt. Man könnte Codes scannen man könnte Analyse machen AI technisch
was da drinnen ist was man denn als nächstes wieder macht. Man könnte unglaublich viel
machen an Kühlschränken um die zu verbessern aber was zum größten Teil gemacht wird ist
man pappt ein Display vorne an den Kühlschrank und sagt das ist ein smarter Kühlschrank
oder noch schlimmer man macht eine Kamera in den Kühlschrank und sagt ja das ist jetzt
ein smarter Kühlschrank. Auf der anderen Seite gäbe es vieles und ich habe das in Kombination
so noch nicht gesehen. Gerade was was Codes scannen kann und sowas. Der hat während der
Fahrt ein Update gemacht ja nice. So was wobei ich denke dass es das teilweise sogar
schon geben könnte aber wenn nicht ist das auch was. Wie gesagt was ich halt meine ist
man macht den Kühlschrank nicht dadurch smart weil man einfach ein Display dran pappt oder
eine Kamera rein packt oder sowas. Das ist unsinnig. Zumal ich auch der Meinung bin wenn
du wirklich gute smarte Heim Elektronik Geräte bauen willst sei es ein Kühlschrank sei es
meinetwegen auch ein Toaster oder eine Waschmaschine das wichtigste für mich ist nicht dass die
irgendwie eine Hersteller App für Smartphone haben die geil aussieht und ist das nur damit
funktioniert. Wichtig ist dass das die Möglichkeit hat in irgendeiner Art und Weise mit offenen
Schnittstellen darauf zuzugreifen. Weil so ein Kühlschrank hast du 10-15 Jahre. Sag
jetzt einfach mal warum sollst du den Kühlschrank austauschen wenn der Kühlschrank geht halt
einfach und wenn er kaputt ist tauscht ihn aus ansonsten behältst ihn bis er verreckt.
Und dass diese Smartphone App in 5 Jahren schon nicht mehr funktioniert ist relativ
hoch beziehungsweise dass die keine Updates mehr bekommen ist relativ hoch und man möchte
vielleicht die dann auch anderweitig integrieren also es ist wichtig dass man möglichst simpel
auf diese smarten Geräte zugreifen kann. Sei es eine Web Schnittstelle sei es MQTT das
einfachste dürfte tatsächlich sein man macht eine ganz normale Schnittstelle eine ganz
normale Web Schnittstelle wo man sich Sachen abrufen kann. Weil eins ist sicher normale
Getrequests Http Getrequests die sind auch in 30 Jahren noch angesagt. Aber da haben
die Hersteller keinen Bock drauf besser eigene App. Ja dass es den Herstellern vorschreibt
ist klar aber ich glaube deswegen ist eines der Gründe warum es jetzt nicht durchsetzt.
Ok und warum haben wir sie nicht wenn wir sie jetzt schon haben könnten. Wenn es sich
lohnen würde sowas jetzt herzustellen würde man das doch machen. Da muss jemand diese
Robbe. Kennt ihr diese Robbe aus japanischen Altersheimen die man da streicheln kann diese
weiße Robbe. Kannste ja jetzt schon machen. Machst eine Websocket Verbindung und da drüber
dann dein Get. War da kein richtiges Get aber du kannst ja über Websockets denken. Theoretisch
kannst du Http über Websockets machen wenn man das will. Wüsste nicht genau warum aber
man kann das machen ja. Ja also können wir es doch nicht machen weil solang es die Technik
nicht gibt. Gut das kannst du zu allem sagen dass es im Prinzip nur eine Geldfrage ist
ja. Also das ist nahezu alles nur eine Geld und Zeitfrage. Wir könnten jetzt auch schon
auf dem Mars sein hätten wir da vor 60 Jahren weiter gemacht mit sehr viel Geld und sehr
viel Manpower und sehr viel Zeit. Es ist halt immer eine Frage der Sinnhaftigkeit. Eine
Fress Schnittstelle. Selbst wenn der Kühlschrank mit Soap XML funktioniert ist auch ok. Hauptsache
irgendwelche offenen Schnittstellen wo man drauf zugreifen kann. Also darauf wird es
definitiv rauslaufen. Also eins kann ich euch sagen wenn neue Technologie sich in einem
Bereich durchsetzt dann ist es bei Porn. So wie man das bei VHS gesehen hat wie man das
bei Blu-Rays und vor allem bei VR gesehen hat. Es ist immer so. Und wenn es die Möglichkeit
gibt Webroboter zu bauen dann gibt es die als erstes. Das erste was es geben wird sind
irgendwelche Anime Weep Porn Roboter. Ich sage es euch. Man will es nicht wahr haben
aber so wird es sein. So wird es sein wie bei vielen anderen Technologien auch. Gibt
es Stauksauber Roboter und Meh Roboter. Das stimmt auch wieder. Ich weiß halt nicht ob
humane Roboter überhaupt das Ding ist. Was wäre denn jetzt der Vorteil davon wenn du
einen Roboter hast der mit dem Rasenmäher durch deinen Garten fährt anstatt ein Meh
Roboter. Außer dass es Weird Champ aussieht. Fabestorm danke für den Sub. Na ja was gucken
wir uns jetzt an zeig mal her. Ja das ist ein Gebiet da haben wir eh große Probleme
in Zukunft. Hauptsächlich weil es wahrscheinlich außer Roboter keiner mehr machen will. Also
komm wir lassen uns eine Runde Level Capture Baiten. Level Capture Bait ist real. Battle
Feast finally adds Fanfavorite Mode. Oh finally. Finally gibt es irgendwas warum man das Spiel
mal wieder länger als 2 Stunden spielen sollte. Inklusive Addon. Weil wisst ihr wie lange
ich das Addon gespielt habe. Addon die Season 1. Ich habe es gespielt für mein Video 5
Runden oder so. Und ich habe es hier im Stream 5 Runden gespielt. Ich habe 10 Runden insgesamt
gespielt und es wieder uninstalled. Fertig. Weil ich gar nicht weiß ob ich uninstalled
habe aber ich werde es uninstallen. So bald wozu. Fertig. So. Achja. Big Changes. Big Changes
bei DICE bedeutet sie sind in eine Textdatei gegangen und haben zeig mal die Spielerzahlen.
Ja mach ich. Mach ich. Sie sind in eine Textdatei gegangen aber vorne mal schnell New World
Lurken. Ah nice. Haha das ist auch geil. Ich habe am Anfang gesagt als das Spiel rausgekommen
ist und gerade in Deutschland haben sie eine riesige Kampagne gefahren mit Let's Playern
die das spielen und die ganzen Casual Noobs sind dann dahin gerannt weil ihr Lieblings
Let's Player das spielt und haben sich aufgeregt über die Server Cues. Ich habe noch gesagt
Leute wartet mal 2-3 Monate ab ihr werdet euch zurück wünschen dass es Zeiten gibt
die Zeiten wieder mit den Server Cues weil 3 Monate später sind die Server leer. Ich
habe es selten gesehen dass so schnell in diesem Umfang Spielerzahlen verloren wurden. Man
muss sich das mal vorstellen. Sie sind innerhalb von 1. Stimmt nicht ganz. September, Oktober
fehlt da. Innerhalb von 2-3 Monaten. Sag mal 3 Monaten. Innerhalb von 3 Monaten sind die
um 850.000. Krasser Scheiß Alter. Also Battlefield. Battlefield Zahl. Zeig mal her. Oh guck mal
da. Ist wieder hoch und jetzt am Wochenende ist es wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen. Guckt
euch das mal an. Also ich denke das wird vielleicht noch 1-2 Wochen so gehen dann ist wieder Ruhe.
Dann haben das alle ausprobiert und gut ist. Weil Content gibt es ja nach wie vor nicht
und es gibt auch sonst nichts weiter sinnigerweise in dem Game. Tja. Lassen wir uns was debaten.
Und was Levelcap hier sagt ist Dice ist in irgendeine Textdatei gegangen in irgendeine
JSON Datei und hat die Map Rotation geändert. Hui. Den Bitcoin ja den können wir uns angucken.
Der ist ein bisschen ja weiß ich ziemlich weit. Runter. Geflutscht. So egal. So vollkommen
egal ob es die Zahlen von Origin. Was auf Epic. Epic gibt es auch Battlefield. Wirklich.
Tatsächlich Kegway. Ist aber egal. Es ist vollkommen wurscht. Meine Trend ist doch überall
der gleiche. Und ob es jetzt. Ich meine mal ernsthaft ob das jetzt im Endeffekt. Wenn
man sich das hier mal anguckt. 2000 Spieler. Ob es jetzt 2000 Spieler sind auf Steam oder
sagen wir mal noch mal 2000 dabei für die anderen Plattformen. Das macht es jetzt nicht
fett. Also wichtig ist der Trend und der Trend ist überall gleich. Wir wissen ja die Spielerzahlen
von den Konsolen auch nicht. Aber wir können davon ausgehen dass der Trend auf den Konsolen
exakt genauso ist. Das wird es wahrscheinlich sogar bald gratis geben. Also die versuchen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit Transactions was zu verdienen. Ja die Leute die sich damals
eine Pizza gekauft haben. Ich finde das ist falsch darüber sich jetzt Gedanken zu machen
weil man muss sich überlegen wie das war. Man hat damals gesagt okay die Pizzeria bietet
für Bitcoins eine Pizza an und jetzt finde ich das angemessen damit zu kaufen. Da konnte
auch niemand mit rechnen. Das ist acht Jahre später richtig krass viel wert ist. Es hätte
genauso gut sein können dass er nie wieder was dafür bekommen hätte. Muss man immer
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehen. Weil es ist genauso wie wenn du dir irgendwelche Börsencrafts
anguckst und sagst ah hätte ich damals Microsoft Apple sonst was gekauft. Das wusstest du
ja nicht. Das kannst du im Nachhinein immer so einfach sagen. Ja aber du wusstest das
ja nicht. Ja mal angenommen nächstes Jahr geht Bitcoin auf neues Rekordniveau. Da würden
alle sagen oh fuck hätte ich heute mal was gekauft. Du weißt es nicht. Kann aber auch
bei 1700 nächstes Jahr sein. So wir lassen uns jetzt weiter Level Cap Gbaiten. Auf Gbaiten
uns. Ich finde es lustig dass Battlefield in letzter Zeit eigentlich nichts irgendwie
spannendes rausbringt. Aber trotzdem diese Videos immer von significant und huge changes
und sonst was reden. Und in Wirklichkeit ist nichts davon significant und huge. Ja gut
das ist gut hoffentlich hoffentlich nur 24 Spieler. Leute ich sag euch was. Wie wärs
mit einer Map Selection. Einfach eine Map Selection in der Spielersuche. Weil dann
könnte man einfach drei Spielmodi anbieten und dann könnte man dort auswählen welche
Map man spielen will und dann würde man nur diese Map spielen die man spielen will oder
diese drei Maps die man spielen will. Ich hab gehört sowas soll möglich sein. Aber
ich glaube bei DICE ist einfach die Technology noch nicht noch nicht da dafür. Stimmt dafür
gibt es auch nicht genug Spieler. Hast du recht.
Wenn ich sage es gibt kein Server Browser habe ich jetzt schon total oft Leute gesehen
in meinen Videos die dann sagen doch doch Max guck mal in Portal da gibt es einen Server
Browser. Die verstehen nicht dass das was komplett anderes ist. Also einen Server Browser
in einem Nischenteil des Games versus der Hauptspiel Modus oder das Ding wofür man das eigentlich
geholt hat oder naja wofür es beworben wurde. Wo die Leute drauf scharf sind und den Hauptspiel
Modus oder die Hauptspiel Kategorie da gibt es keinen Server Browser. Und nur weil es
da in Portal irgendwie sowas Nischen mäßiges gibt. So what?
Also eins muss man sagen. DICE hat es in dem Fall ja echt perfektioniert. Die können
viel reden über nichts nichts. Also die reden viel über sehr wenig Inhalt. Was möchte
dann DICE bitteschön an Weekly Roadmaps raushauen. Das Spiel ist acht Monate alt und hat kaum
neue Sachen oder hat im Endeffekt nichts wirklich bekommen. Ja Voice Chat hui ja ein Scoreboard
aber das ist doch nichts an Inhalt. Das Spiel hat in acht Monaten nichts zu bekommen. Was
wollen die denn in ihre Weekly Roadmap schreiben. 8.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo. 9.30 Uhr gehe
ich was futtern. 10.30 Uhr mache ich ein Video auf YouTube. A Day in DICE Developers Life.
Oder was wollen die denn? Was soll auf dieser Roadmap draufstehen?
Also Inhalt zum Game kann es ja schlecht sein.
8.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo. 9.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo. 9.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo.
9.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo. 9.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo. 9.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo.
zwischen Updates und dann sagt DICE, ja wir könnten uns überlegen ob wir nicht auf dieser
Map drei neue Kisten platzieren. Also die Roadmap bei Warzone ist, wir tauschen zwischen
Updates einfach mal die halbe Map aus und bringen eine neue Map mit rein und die Roadmap
bei Battlefield ist, ja man könnte drei Kisten platzieren. Und der nächste Punkt in unserer
Roadmap ist, dass wir die Roadmap für nächste Woche erstellen. Bei dem Typ kann ich nicht
anders wie an was 16 times the detail oder ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie viel wie viel
mal detail mehr hätte Fallout 76 haben sollen. Elder Scrolls 6, das haben sie auch vor vier
Jahren oder so angekündigt und zwar wie, sie haben einen Schriftzug gezeigt und haben
dabei das Elder Scrolls Main Theme für drei Tastendrücke angespielt. Fertig, nice und
seitdem nie wieder was von gehört.
Seriously, wenn die kein Spiel rausbringen mit Mod-Support, ist es ja, also das muss
man ihnen ja tatsächlich lassen, Skyrim ist eines der besten Modding Plattformen allerzeit.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen daran an Half-Life 1, was es da für tausende geile Mods gab,
also von den Möglichkeiten her. Da gibt es so Sachen wie Enderal, wo sie quasi das komplette
Spiel, wo sie quasi nur das Framework drumherum genommen haben, ein komplett eigenes Spiel
gebaut haben, also das machen die schon richtig. Das sorgt ja letztendlich auch für Langlebigkeit
in den Games und dass man sich da nicht darauf verlassen muss, dass sie das mit Inhalt füllen
für die nächsten zehn Jahre ist ja auch gut. Zum Beispiel Games wie Mario Kart, sage ich
jetzt nicht von ungefähr, weil es gab ja eine Custom Strecke für Mario Kart als Mod,
die optisch noch nicht so hundertprozentig an die Originalstrecken rankommt, weil sie
noch Probleme haben mit der Beleuchtung, aber überlegt euch mal, wie cool das wäre, könnte
man einfach mit ordentlichen Mod-Tools Mario Kart Strecken erstellen. Das wäre eines der
beliebtesten Games der Welt. Das wäre das Spiel auf Twitch. Das wäre einfach der riesen
Hype, wenn es da für Möglichkeiten gäbe eigene Strecken zu erstellen. Aber was macht
Nintendo? Nichts. Und bringen irgendwie die Mario Kart Tour Strecken leicht angepasst
dafür raus, nice. Aber überlegt euch mal, wie das Spiel komplett durch die Decke gehen
würde, könntest du in Mario Kart Custom Strecken erstellen. Und ich meine damit nicht, dass
sie einen Mario Kart Maker machen sollen. Das meine ich damit gar nicht. Es ist nämlich
ein Unterschied, ob du einen Mario Kart Maker, Dungeon Maker oder sonst was hast oder ob du
einfach Zugriff auf die Entwicklungstools hast. Wenn du dir nämlich Skyrim anguckst
oder auch davor, wenn man sich mal die... Wo sind die Baldur's Gate Leute? Black Isle
Studios? Ich bin gar nicht mehr sicher. Wenn man sich die Neverwinter Nights Mod-Tools
anguckt und sowas, da hast du gesehen, dass die Leute das Spiel zum großen Teil auch
mit diesen Tools entwickelt haben. Und das ist ein Unterschied, ob du den Leuten einen
casual freundlichen... Mario & Games waren die Divinity. Das sind wieder andere. Ich meine
nicht die Baldur's Gate 3 machen, ich meine die alten Dinger. Oder guck dir Source Engine
Sachen an. Genau. Das ist kein Level Editor für Casuals wie Mario Maker, sondern das
sind halt die Tools, mit denen die Entwickler zum größten Teil auch die Inhalte dafür
erstellt haben. Das ist ein Unterschied und da kannst du halt viel mehr machen. Das kann
nicht jeder Kacknoob, aber es muss auch nicht jeder Kacknoob Strecken erstellen. Belegt
euch mal, du hättest wirklich die Möglichkeit mit ordentlichen Tools, was ja Fan-Made mittlerweile
halbwegs sogar geht für Mario Kart, Nintendo mag das halt nicht, du hättest wirklich offiziell
die Möglichkeit, richtig neue Strecken mit ordentlichen Entwicklungstools für Mario
Kart zu erstellen. Alter das Spiel würde auch auf Twitch, das würde überall komplett
durch die Decke gehen, weil das ist einfach ein ultra spaßiges Game und wenn es da jetzt
noch abgedrehten geilen Fan-Content gäbe und Nintendo kann sich das jetzt gar nicht
ausdenken, was den Fans alles einfallen würde. Ja das erste was es gäbe, wäre Prop Hunt
in Mario Kart, bin ich mir sicher, das ist immer einer der ersten Modi, die skippt. Ja
da kannst du dann, ich bin auf der Map versteckt, ich bin irgendein Shy Guy, der da oben auf
der Pyramide rumläuft oder so. Da gäbe es die krassesten Mods überhaupt und das würde
das Spiel, das würde komplett durch die Decke gehen. Natürlich die Frage, ob Nintendo
dann ein paar Jahre ein neues Mario Kart verkaufen könnte oder so viele Leute noch sich die
StreckendLCs kaufen würden. Das ist richtig, das stimmt schon. Aber es würde das Spiel
unglaublich langlebig und unglaublich gehyped machen. Egal, wir lassen uns weiter tschüben.
Also Mod Support ist immer noch eines der geilsten, also gut gemachten Mod Support.
Mod Support muss ja gar nicht, wisst ihr eigentlich warum so viele Spiele früher Mod Support
hatten? Das war kein Mod Support im eigentlichen Sinn, die Entwickler haben einfach ihre Entwickler
Tools dabei gelegt. Half Life 1 hattest du WorldCraft? Hieß das glaube ich noch? WorldCraft?
Ja, WorldCraft hieß das Ding in Half Life 1. Heute heißt es Hammer, früher hieß es WorldCraft.
Die haben einfach ihre Entwickler Tools dabei gelegt. Und fast jedes Echtzeitstrategie Spiel
damals, guckt euch auch die alten Command & Conquer Teile an, die hatten einen Editor
dabei und das war zu 90%, vielleicht nicht alle Features komplett, aber das war zu 90%
eben der Editor, mit dem die Missionen für dieses Spiel erstellt wurden vom Hersteller.
Also das war kein Mod Support in dem Sinn, dass man gesagt hätte, ja wir machen das
jetzt extra, nein, die haben einfach ihre Entwickler Tools freigegeben. Sachen wie
WorldCraft 3, also die ganzen WorldCraft 3 Mods wären ja gar nicht möglich gewesen
mit einem minimalistischen Casual-freundlichen Editor. WPM, ja habe ich schon, ich bin nicht
sonderlich schnell im Schreiben, vor allem nicht fehlerfrei. So und das war halt richtig
geil, deswegen gab es da auch so viel geilen Content und deswegen konntest du damals quasi
jahrelang Spiele spielen, weil es einfach Poggers Content am laufenden Band und von Leuten,
die das Spiel kannten und wussten, wie man gute Sachen macht, gab. Es gab auch viel,
es gab sehr viel Müll-Content, also 90% der Mods, würde ich sagen, waren Müll, aber es
egal, es gab einfach saubermissig viele und auch richtig gute, ja. Ego CS ist ja im Prinzip
ein Mod, war ursprünglich gewesen. Dota auch, genau. Also wie gesagt, das ist das beste,
wie man Spiele langlebig machen kann und das war halt früher mehr oder weniger normal,
weil die ihre Entwickler Tools mitgebracht haben. Und die haben halt dann gesagt, ja
entweder ihr arbeitet euch da ein oder ihr habt Pech gehabt, aber du hattest halt die
umfangreichen Möglichkeiten, was zu machen. Ohne Scheiß Overwatch wäre ein so viel geileres
Game, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Overwatch könnte eines der besten Competitive, Casual, könnte
eines der besten Spiele für alle sein, gäbe es die Entwickler Tool beziehungsweise gäbe
es die Möglichkeit, ordentliche Custom Maps zu machen. Weil man muss halt sagen, die Overwatch
Maps sind halt zur Hälfte ultra kacke, gerade die ganzen 2CP-Dinger, also gut, dass die
rausfliegen und Blizzard kann keine Maps bauen. Also ich finde, die Overwatch Maps, die sind
halt vom Detailgrad und vom Design her, sind die cool, also Art-Abteilung hat Blizzard,
aber die Maps sind vom Gameplay her rotz, ganz ehrlich, ich sage euch, das ist meine
Meinung von den Overwatch Maps, es gibt ein paar Maps, die sind okay, Kingsrow zum Beispiel
finde ich ganz nice, aber ansonsten, die meisten Maps sind einfach langweilige Schlauchlevel
ohne Finesse, also Overwatch Maps sind einfach total langweilig, zum größten Teil schlecht
designte Shooter Maps, könnte man wirklich Maps entwerfen, für Overwatch wäre das eines
der besten Spiele der letzten Jahre und wäre es immer noch, es wäre auch nicht so untergegangen,
weil Blizzard nichts an Content rausbringt. Es ist doch nicht ohne Grund so, dass StarCraft,
die Maps, die dort gespielt werden, die wechseln ja auch immer wieder, niemand spielt Blizzard
Maps, das sind alles Custom Maps und der Map Pool wechselt da auch regelmäßig, das sind
alles Custom Maps, die ganzen StarCraft sind alles Custom Maps.
The same. This applies to modding as well. He stated that Starfield will be a dream for
its modding community. The Resident Evil franchise had several exciting announcements this week,
Resident Evil Village is getting a new expansion called Shadows of Rose. It'll be based around
the protagonist's daughter from the base game. Capcom stated that the new DLC is much harder
than the base game. Village is also getting a third-person mode that'll make it play
like a combination of the original Resident Evil games and their modern remakes. All
this new content is available as part of the Golden Edition bundle that will launch on
October 28. Highly realistic tactical FPS Ready or Not has been temporarily delisted
from Steam with that explanation. The game was removed a week after the developers added
a nightclub level depicting a mass shooting event. The devs say Valve hasn't clarified
why the game was removed, but they're working to resolve the situation. It's likely the
game's dedication to realism has pushed... Wie ist denn das eigentlich? Meine blöde Frage,
hatte schon jemand mal die Variante, er hat ein Steam-Game gekauft, runtergeladen und dann
wurde es von Steam genommen. Was passiert dann? Kann man das dann noch spielen? Kann
man das nun nicht mehr herunterladen? Wird das deinstalliert lokal bei einem? Kann man
es anklicken, aber nicht mehr starten? Man kann es nun nicht neu kaufen, oder wie? Achso,
also man kann es bloß nicht mehr kaufen. Okay.
Hat das hier mal von euch gespielt? Ich stelle mir die Steuerung auf mobile oder cheatet
jeder mit dem Controller? Spielt das einfach jeder mit dem Controller und fickt die ganzen
PLEPS am Touchscreen weg? Oder wie ist das?
Na gut, holen wir was aus, excuse me.
Leaker Tom Henderson, der sagt, dass er das Prototyp dieses neuen Pro-Controllers gesehen hat.
Er sagt, es beinhaltet
removable analog sticks, removable stick units beneath the analog sticks,
Trigger-Stops, Rear-Buttons und removable grips.
Die removable analog sticks
As it offends in a scav controller, oder?
...would last someone to actually replace them if they develop something like stick drift issues or just wear out.
Ubisoft hat gesagt, es würde die Zukunft von Assassin's Creed irgendwann im September entdecken.
Fans speculate, that that event would be used to reveal the rumored Assassin's Creed Infinity Game,
a free-to-play, multi-era, live-service title.
Oh nein, please, please!
Das hört sich wieder nach Ultra, wir wollen ganz viel Geld machen, haben aber eigentlich keine gute Idee für das Game an.
A remaster of the original Assassin's Creed Game is coming.
In the new anniversary trailer of the series, particular attention was put on Assassin's Creed 1.
Fans noticed minor lighting tweaks and color changes compared to the original game.
It also sports a new logo.
Of course, time will tell, as everything will hopefully be revealed in September.
Newly released God of War merchandise has fans speculating about the game's release date.
The highly anticipated sequel, God of War Ragnarok, was initially set to launch in 2021,
but was pushed back to sometime this year.
An online store has listed God of War Ragnarok merchandise with a release date of October 2022.
According to developers on Twitter, the game won't be delayed again,
meaning an October release date is looking more likely.
District 9 and Elysium director Neil Blockamp is set to direct a Gran Turismo movie for Sony.
It's supposedly going to be re-released in August of 2023.
Reports indicate that isn't the usual video game adaptation.
Instead, the film will follow a teenage Gran Turismo player whose gaming skills lead them to become an actual professional race car driver.
Other than that, very few additional details are known, but production at Columbia Pictures is starting soon.
It'll be led by the same producers that made the recent Uncharted movie.
Oh yeah!
During their Overwatch 2 live stream, Activision Blizzard confirmed that the sequel would be an always-on, constantly-evolving, free-to-play game.
It'll drop the original's loot box model in favor of a battle pass and an in-game store.
Each season will run for nine weeks and include either a new map or a new hero every time.
Not to mention new weekly challenges...
Moment, Moment, Moment!
Die wollen alle neun Wochen eine neue Map und einen neuen Held releasen?
Oder, oder ein neuer...
Das geht nicht?
Wir haben, also, wir haben bei DICE gesehen, das ist nicht möglich.
Also, es ist wirklich, wörtlich genommen, unmöglich.
Das geht, das geht gar nicht.
Chico verdeckt die oberste Zeile.
Was macht Chico denn für Dinger hier?
So, jetzt verdeckt Chico nicht mal die oberste Zeile.
Ja, aber das, was ist denn mit denen los?
DICE sagt nein, genau, das geht gar nicht.
Seriös, aber eben...
Wie diese Damen.
So, jetzt geht's einfach los.
Ja, los mit dem minimize Setback.
Desktop?
Thinking!
Deswegen, Some queen praised the menu!
It's 68% action.
The release date for Survival FPS Stalker 2 has recently been pushed back to 2023.
This is because the development team GSC Gameworld was based in the Ukraine.
The extended Xbox and Bethesda showcase this week included a short video about what the
developers have been dealing with since the Russia invasion began.
The video shows the bombed out offices of the developers as well as different devs in uniform.
The community manager for the game also now uses a bathroom for an office.
The studio is currently transitioning to a new office space in Prague.
They have stated that once things are up and running, development on Stalker 2 will resume.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll catch you next time.
This is Levelcap signing off.
What happens if you cut off CPU Pins?